my first ever time on screen was always
I went to the I was in my 20s had never
been done anything on stage or screen
before and I went along to the Jobcentre
and they sent everyone all the waves and
strays all of us they sent all of us to
be a film extras in a Welsh film that
was filming nearby and off we went and
got our 30 quid for the day well dogs in
the neck it's the boss but this was a
horse and the horses job all year to do
was walk through the back of the shot
was a period drama and every single time
the director shouted action I kid you
not the horse got an erection and
everything this little guy whose job it
was it's the little guy whose sole job
it was a five could work out was to run
out with a bicycle pump in a bucket and
as soon as they went action horse said
darling this bloke went and this was his
penis this went was just back in and
they've got cut and then they'd go start
again they've got action God I thought
every single time he said action what's
he doing with the bicycle but the
bicycle club all erecting he won't do
undirected well this is on tons of Wells
blow jobs
a lot of women out there experience for
this that would want the number of the
trainer of the horse what happened with
the horse's penis wiggle at that huge
and then this little man would run out
suck water up from the bucket into the
pump and then spray the horse's penis
with cold water busy and then the penis
would just sort of go back not say going
in Agoura action oh it would go don't
you I've met
so stressful and I'm so tired and I was
so lonely here Dave and it went
immediately into Oh barge I just despise
you